Get your resume set.
Here is mine!
No, this is 30 pages long.
Make it one page and keep it simple.
Got it!
A good resume has your background info and skills,...
...but don't put in everything.
No one cares if you're a prom king,...
...unless your job interview is for prom kings.
Here is resume!
No, you wrote this in crayon.
But you said keep it simple.
A good resume has to be presentable.
Got it.
That means no typos and easy to read,...
...but not too easy to read.
Don't just write Hodor over and over again,...
...unless you're applying for a job carrying around a little psychic kid with no legs.
Here is resume.
There are no typos, and it is easy to read.
This just says, "My name is Mario."
But I have no background or skills!
Just print out my resume and put your name on it.
Got it!
For the record, you should never do that.
But we'd never get through this video otherwise.